hören sie bleibt deutschlands
umstrittenster deutschlands meist
kritisierte ministerin und das
ausgerechnet jetzt in diesen
kriegszeiten unsere
verteidigungsminister in christine
lambrecht sie erinnern sich hier dran an
die heli affäre auch um ihren sohn die
sie irgendwie einfach ausgesessen hat
bei aller heftigen kritik sie erinnern
sich an das ganze hin und her rund um
die waffenlieferung ihre immer wieder
unglücklichen äußerungen und diesmal
diesmal würden uns die ministerin ein
panzer erklären im bundestag sehen über
die nicht nur soldaten längst den kopf
schütten
das ist der unterschied zwischen der
entscheidung der marder nicht zu liefern
grund der entscheidungen einen gepard zu
liefern was hier das substanzielle
unterschiedlich erlebt hat ist kein
panzer das ist der unterschied wird
anders eingeordnet zumindest ist das die
einordnung des generalinspekteurs
beispielsweise oder der militärischen
beratung der reeder ist kein kanzler das
ist der unterschied wieder gepaart ist
ja dafür da ins beispiel auch kritische
infrastruktur zu schützen dadurch dass
er mit diesem rohr dann in die luft
schießt und dort sehr weit objekte eben
auch erfassen kann das kann der panzer
nicht der retter ist kein kanzler das
ist der unterschied